have you met Seinfeld yeah I had lunch
with him about two weeks ago or
performed in front of him he yelled at
me yeah and it's very surreal like I
used to watch this guy when I was 11 in
my living room with my parents and now
he's yelling at me and I [__] up on
stage and I I he gives you he's like you
got to do this amount of time and
there's no light or clock so you just
have to know it it's a lot of pressure
it is especially when you're open for
him yeah so I [__] up when I went
short because I was so scared of going
long yeah I better just go short that's
safer yeah but I went so short that he
wasn't there he wasn't ready by the side
of the stage right so I didn't know what
to do and I panicked and I went back out
and that was a huge mistake because now
they're like oh we already don't know
you we're waiting for this guy and now
you're back yeah and so I started
getting heckled and then I ran off stage
and he was like what are you doing yeah
so then he went on and killed and then
he came back and oh but he did all right
yeah he killed yeah because they were so
happy to see him right they hated me
yeah you almost set him up better by
coming out